a little over two years ago an attempt
to process some of my frustration with
JK Rowling I made a comedy sketch
mocking her then recent actions and it
ended with this gag
Voldemort identified as a woman God damn
it I ended that sketch with a joke about
her drawing a direct parallel between
the villains of her books and trans
people
because it seemed absurd and a lot of
people commented on it saying I had to
double check to make sure she hadn't
done that
today
there's a unique kind of pain for having
your attempt at comedic exaggeration
turn into reality a few years down the
line I'm not surprised that I'm well
past being able to be disappointed by
her but if you ever needed evidence that
you can't even parody
the transphobic mindset because of how
extreme it is on its own
there you go